en este vídeo lo que haré es dibujar un
cuadrado entonces ya que lo tenemos que
sabemos sobre los cuadrados sabemos que
en los cuadrados todos los lados miden
lo mismo cierto tienen la misma longitud
entonces si este lado nivel x
todos los demás también miden x ajá y
también sabemos que estos ángulos que se
forman son ángulos rectos eso es lo que
hace a un cuadrado ahora la pregunta que
quiero hacer es si las longitudes de los
lados del cuadrado son proporcionales a
su área entonces piensa los puntos al
vídeo y piensa en si las longitudes de
los lados de un cuadrado son
proporcionales al área del cuadrado y
bueno para pensar en esto lo que haré es
dibujar una tabla y en una de las
columnas de esta tabla pongo longitud de
un lado longitud
lado y estará dado por x entonces esa es
la primera columna y en la segunda
columna vamos a poner el área cuál es el
área el área será igual a uno de los
lados al cuadrado o lo puedes también
ver como base por altura entonces lo
podemos ver como x por equis o
simplemente x al cuadrado entonces vamos
a elegir algunos valores para x y veamos
cuál es el área del cuadrado si x es
igual a 1 el área será uno por uno eso
es igual a 1 si x es igual a 2 el área
será igual a 2 x 2
eso es 4 si x es igual a 3 el área será
igual a 3 x 3
eso es 9 y yo puedo seguir pero creo que
con esto con estos puntos ya podemos
pensar en si la longitud de un lado del
cuadrado es proporcional al área del
cuadrado o si el área es proporcional a
la longitud de un lado del cuadrado
una de las maneras en las que tú puedes
pensar en proporcionalidad es en si la
razón entre la longitud de un lado y el
área correspondiente siempre es
constante entonces queremos ver la razón
entre la longitud de un lado y el área o
lo que es lo mismo el área entre la
longitud de un lado así que tenemos área
sobre longitud de un lado y para esto
para hacer los cálculos vamos a agregar
otra columna a nuestro tabla muy bien
entonces veamos la razón del área y la
longitud de un lado no importa el orden
que tome siempre y cuando sea constante
entonces tenemos área sobre longitud de
un lado longitud de un lado muy bien
ahora veamos cuál es la razón en la
primera fila tenemos 1 sobre 1 eso es
igual a 1
y en la segunda fila tenemos que el área
sobre la longitud de un lado eso es 4
sobre 2 esto es igual a 2
entonces ya ni siquiera es necesario ver
el tercer ejemplo la razón aquí sería el
área que es 9 sobre la longitud de un
lado que es 39 sobre 3 eso es igual a 3
nota que que no estoy estoy obteniendo
un valor distinto cada vez no estoy
obteniendo un valor constante no obtengo
una razón constante entre el área y la
longitud así que estos no son
proporcionales no son proporcionales eso
nos dice que la longitud de un lado del
cuadrado y el área del cuadrado no son
proporcionales y si lo observas tiene
mucho sentido que la razón es de hecho
igual a la longitud de un lado que
cambia dependiendo de la longitud de un
lado y eso es porque estamos elevando al
cuadrado literalmente estamos tomando x
al cuadrado si aquí tienes un lado que
mide x entonces su área del cuadrado
será x al cuadrado y la razón será x al
cuadrado sobre x y esto siempre es igual
a x porque x al cuadrado es igual a x x
x entonces tienes x x x sobre x eso es
igual a x lo podemos ver aquí por lo
tanto no es proporcional y terminamos